my guest tonight has directed some of
the most successful comedies of the past
15 years including the four-year-old
virgin knocked up
and this is 40 his latest the king of
staten island
is uh available on blu-ray
digital and on-demand please welcome
our friend judd apatow judd how are you
i'm happy to be here happy to i wish i
was at largo though
i know you know we should uh mention to
people i'm at the largo theater
but i think the last live gig i did
was with you that's right and sandler
and a bunch of other people we were idle
erica that's right eric idle bo
burnham that was a crazy show it was a
great show
you hosted it and it was here at the
largo i think we have a photograph
of you and i on stage and also backstage
all of us
and i swear to god i think kovid shut
things down
days later and this place is now
empty except for my skeleton crew
this is my last memory of a live
performance was here and that was a
great night
that was a weirdly magical evening
i mean it was almost so great that uh
it was you know it was a good last one
you know it was like if there was going
to be alaska because what if the last
one
you just bombed terribly right front of
the crowd and that you had to sit with
that for a year
yeah not that that's ever happened but
had i bombed that night i would have
felt like oh my god
um i'm through i'm through in the
business and and being here at largo
would have been a terrible
experience for me but i had a very uh i
had a fun night we all had a fun night
and that's what i think about every day
i come in here is we got to get back to
that place where we can
we can come back here all of us do a
show
and get each other very sick exactly i
you know i love logo i do you know a
benefit there once a month for the last
four years and i have so many amazing uh
memories of
being there one of my worst memories now
that you mentioned it
is you know before show you get nervous
so you use the largo
toilet yeah it's kind of right in the
center of things it's a very small
backstage it's right uh right back there
yeah yeah so i was there kind of early
use the restroom for a you know pre-show
deal with it situation and then dealt
with it in an ugly way
and then as i walked out the door
jackson brown was
heading in one of those situations where
you want to go
jackson you want to pull a jim carrey do
not
go in there poor jackson brandon you
know what he hasn't been seen since
he hasn't been seen i think he died
after
after he used that restroom he brought
me so much joy
all throughout my whole life and that's
what i did to him
he was humming doctor my eyes have seen
the years walked right in
and then was gone he's just dead now
tell me what you're doing uh are you
keeping up with people during pandemic
are you are you zooming with a lot of
people what's going on
i think the one thing that i've noticed
uh is
you know you you check in with people
and you realize who you care about
because that's who you check in with
right like you go hey i haven't talked
to so and so in a little while
i don't know how they're doing basically
you realize who you love
you realize who you love but you also
realize who doesn't like you at all
because they don't check in on you now
that it's been about
six seven months you just go wow that
person must hate me because they don't
know if i'm just dead
in my house right now they they they do
not care for me at all
you know it just occurred to me this is
the first time we've talked
maybe in covid so maybe
neither one of us really cares about the
other one that's true
because i did your podcast also right
before covid
yeah uh conan needs a friend we realized
on the on the podcast that we were not
going to be friends that we had the
ability
because we live like 200 yards from each
other and we don't
do it and so i think i i feel
comfortable
knowing yeah it's not on the table it's
always going to be about
here largo but you know when you're
hurting inside
like something's happening in your life
you are not going to call me and share i
don't think i'm going to call you in
that situation i may call you
the only reason i'd call you is to say
uh your books
are much too close to your fireplace
that i might say
that is a fire hazard that is a terrible
fire hazard
there's a lot of uh a lot of hoarding
here yeah
uh i i i'm a hoarder this is what i've
realized is that i
have just so much stuff around me i mean
this is how much i
hoard i've got a pete holmes uh
mouse pad
[Laughter]
no one has a pete holmes mouse pad no
pete got it for me so i wouldn't forget
about him after crashing he wants to be
on my hand that's
a new level it's a new level of sad well
our show is done
but i'm getting you a mouse pad of
myself so you have to keep thinking
about me
exactly yeah yeah no hang on to that
that's uh that's a that's a valuable
thing to have pete holmes checked in on
me
yeah of course he did you and he you
guys care about each other
that's right you and i are dead inside
yes that's true that's true do you feel
uh that that's what you've learned about
yourself in this time because i think a
lot about what am i supposed to
be learning during this pause during
this purgatory
and uh none of it's been good i don't
feel like any of it has been good i feel
like show business right now
is a phantom limb like we're all trying
to pretend
it's still there but it's not there like
you're in largo right now
pretending show business exists i'm
doing my best
to keep this facade going that there is
show business yes but there isn't show
business
you know and uh there's nothing there's
just and everything's a zoom
like i can't get used to when i read a
review of a play
it's just a shoot picture of two zoom
squares like you read a review in the
new york times of
they say like it's a stunning new play
and it's four people on a zoom
and there's no way that that that's what
show business has become
do you find that when you're on a zoom
you think if you fart people can't hear
it
i think that uh that's all i think
that's pretty much all i've been
thinking that the whole time
you know life and it's all i think
no i don't think they can hear it it
can't get through the sound it can't get
through the zoom
now are you you uh i'm
what are you watching because i have
started watching stuff
i never would have watched otherwise i'm
watching this show
that people tell me it's been on forever
that's called selling sunset
it's like a uh and everyone watching is
like conan where have you been
but it's a reality tv show where they
just sell
uh upscale real estate in west hollywood
i started watching that uh and
i don't like real estate agents i don't
want to spend time with them
in my free time i don't either
i'm not even saying i'm enjoying it
it's a sign of the times that i'm
watching a show and my assistant told me
oh it doesn't really get
good till season three yes this is what
i will say
and i'm watching and that's what people
say and i'm watching it i'm watching
this show
and i'm going like yeah it's still not
really nothing's happening but i guess i
have to watch
two full seasons till something picks up
i never had that kind of patience for a
show before
you used to hear that about the wire
yeah you gotta get to the seasons of the
idris elba it's like i think that's
season three or four
like okay so i need to get 30 in
whoever by the way season one of the
wire is great so it was a lie
whoever whoever said that about any i
mean but
are you doing that now or you because
people have that's a common thing i keep
hearing is
just get through five seasons and then
it really picks up
but you've got to watch the first five
you gotta get halfway through season
four game of thrones
then it really kicks in
[Laughter]
my wife and i we have so many uh you
know binging fights
we're always fighting about that because
uh she does not follow
any binge rule uh like
i will go uh somewhere uh you know like
say we get like a little tiff
you know get a little tiff and we're
watching uh like we're watching prime
suspect starring helen mirren which is
on hulu great english
show classic old show i like how you
said helen mirren
helen you went starring helen mirren
like what are you gonna do about it it's
not a bar fight alan mirren
what are you going to do about it you
want to take me on now
is it good so yes so it stars um
helen mirren and uh now it's woody allen
it's helen mirren and
so we get to like a little a little tip
about something
and then you know uh next time i turn it
on she's three
seasons forward she's left three seasons
and also doesn't care like
i'll go well what's going on she's like
google it
google it go read a summary of previous
seasons
see to me that's a contract if i'm
watching something with my wife and we
there's an implicit implied contract
that this is a show we watch together
then later on i find out that she's gone
a whole season ahead of me
that's like waking up in the wilderness
and your partner
left early in the morning and took the
thermos and the food
you know what i mean and you land and
they're just gone
they went up the trail without you
that's a betrayal
yeah my my uh my wife watched uh the
last season of the crown without me
and then you're in a situation where
you're like well when am i gonna get to
watch it alone
i don't have this kind of time i only
got eight hours
where you're gonna let me hang out alone
to catch up on the crown
we have to be in sync as a couple this
is very important
we watch a lot of dateline i find that
you know for some reason that's our
comfort
show yeah dateline because it's very
it's you know it's a about murder
generally but for some reason the way
they edit it they cut away before anyone
has feelings
you know they they just briskly move
through the murder you know you'll see a
documentary and something there's a
murder
and people cry and they feel and you're
devastated but dateline it's it's kind
of balancing
and lights through murder i think it's
strange too because i agree with you i
love uh dateline and i find it strange
that murder has become our comfort food
do you know what i mean yeah it's just
this is where the body was found the
head's missing but we found one of the
feet
and you're watching it like this is
this is chicken soup for the soul you
know i'm not sure why that is
i i don't know if it's like at least i
haven't been murdered or
life is better than this but also i do
feel like i'm
i'm experiencing it with them but also i
enjoy the hosts
because they're just so strange and they
ask like weird
questions ever since bill hader did
impressions of every
host i only think of bill while i watch
the show because they're always just
going like
well that must have felt good and and i
just think of bill like it's like his
head is um
yeah he ruined it for everybody bill
hater ruined it for everybody
uh are you getting a lot of good time
with your kids are you getting some
quality time
i feel like everything's changed with
the kids because in the beginning we had
this
feeling like you know the one good part
of this is
we're going to spend a lot of time with
the kids
and at some point the kids are letting
us know
that they've had enough yeah of us and
it's
way too much and they would like us to
go away
and and it hurts like i could feel it
now like too much parents because you
know when we were kids we didn't want to
hang out with our parents
we all have this expectation they want
to hang out with us
which they don't no but we grew up in a
different time my parents
when i was growing up it was made very
clear everyone stay away from everybody
nobody let's just get through life let's
get to the grave
and not talk about anything let's not
look at each other
uh you know now then this became this
whole thing that we're expected to
really live and enjoy with each other as
we grow up
that never happened before that's a new
thing
yeah the whole idea that you're supposed
to be your kid's best friend no
that's awful terrible your parents are
your best friends
no of course not
do you have a lot of common with them
it reminds me norm mcdonald i think once
said that he
he said i went home for uh christmas uh
and uh it was terrible i accidentally
made eye contact with my father
i thought that i can relate to i was
thinking
i know is it your your daughter
iris is i think
uh this is her senior year is she
driving yet
uh she is uh driving but
she's supposed to take her driver's test
but i don't know if you're allowed to
take a driver's test right now i
i think there's like an 11 month backup
so i'm happy about that i want to delay
her driving as much as possible she's
kind of lazy
about getting those things done and then
i'm
purposely not getting on the wait list
for the test so that she's like
22 before it happens yeah i want my kids
to be in their mid-50s
when they start driving does she have to
get her own car
then when it's time for her to drive is
she gonna have to get her own car
this is a good question because uh
there's some expectation that we'll get
her something
um my i got mod uh a volvo
you know you try to get a safe car uh
yeah i like going to look for cars with
the kids
uh because i the salesman do a funny
thing is
they always [ __ ] talk other kinds of
cars
but act like they're not doing it you
know so if you say like well you know we
had a prius before
those are great cars i mean i i mean i
have a friend who got sterile from one
but it's a pretty car it's a it's a it's
a pretty car uh those batteries
sometimes just explode out of nowhere
and i think there's something in the
battery where you can't put the fire out
but yeah i mean it's it's a handsome car
if you want to go that way you can go
that way
yeah no they always have a way of
disparaging a car that's even famously
great and ex
like just think of the nicest car you
can think of like a mercedes
they'll find a way if you're talking to
someone who doesn't sell a mercedes and
you mention
mercedes are really nice cars they'll
find a way to say that's a crappy car
i mean it's a weird model this year you
kind of look like a klingon when you
drive it
but uh it's i mean you know it's a solid
car
it's a little overpriced it's a little
overpriced but uh
yeah i mean maybe not this year
when we talked on the podcast you talked
about
therapy i don't want to pry too much but
are you still getting therapy
are you still talking to a therapist
during this crazy time i would think you
should be
i always i always talk to therapists i i
have a team
i always have multiple multiple
therapists working act like it's a law
firm
like you have nine therapists i have two
therapists they know about each other
i've had a lot of therapists
i went to a therapist for a while many
years ago it was
he was recommended by uh by gary
chandling by
gary and he uh
and i went to see him for a while and
then i was in the lobby
of his place waiting and there were all
the books that he wrote
and the book that he wrote was uh this
book
total orgasm
and i was like what is going on
with this book and then there's all
these pictures that they're
very they're kind of dirty pictures i'm
not sure what
jesus and i said to gary i said gary you
didn't tell me the
therapist you sent me to is the total
orgasm guy
and gary's like i never talked about
orgasms with him i don't know what that
is
so did you ever bring it up to the
therapist i mean he must know these
incredible secrets
i literally got scared to ask him for
orgasm advice
i should have asked him and then i said
to gary how's it going with that
therapist
like a year later and he's like oh i
left him
i'm like you're not allowed to recommend
a therapist decide you don't like him
and then not tell me that i should leave
too
you have to we have to do it together
that was a betrayal
that was a deep betrayal when we see
gary in the next
plane the next we will i swear to god
we're gonna see gary again
and we should just confront him with all
the things that he did that annoyed us
everything that he did wrong now's the
time we should start really ganging up
on gary
we're gonna have an eternity uh with him
at some point so we might as well just
get it off our chest
and talk about all this stuff there'll
be time to hash it out uh
all right well listen uh upcoming
election i know you're very involved are
you feeling any
one way or the other are you just
nervous like everybody else
like all of us are just thinking
and in addition to covet and everything
else the idea that
this election is going to happen in
weeks is terrifying
just terrifying i find yeah and i and i
track it like
second by second like i am tweeting
i am watching i am stressing uh
leslie decided like she just dips in and
checks
every few days i check minute by minute
she
looks so healthy she looks like she's
regenerating like you know her skin
she's like millie bobby brad
i look like a wartime president i'm just
aging
you look like franklin roosevelt in 1945
seconds before he died exactly
minutes before his death but i'm hopeful
that there's enough people in the
country who have realized
that the experiment was a mistake the
experiment to get that guy
probably wasn't a good idea maybe maybe
the the apprentice guy
can't run the country and that it's a
simple decision
i mean we debate about a lot of things
but it seems kind of simple
at this point i think uh i think what we
should do is take a break from having a
tv host
yes the president with no uh experience
uh um you know with the electorate
and then at maybe a term or two down the
line
uh someone like me would be right with
the country would be ready again
i think if you don't get a haircut till
then
and then you you get your own little
swoop
[Laughter]
then i think then we're all for it i'll
get all the trump people will be like he
kind of reminds me
if by then i'll have some rolled it
around
yeah i'm excited about it and i'm glad
that i have your support
still very worried about your hoarding
uh i just want to say that before we go
you've got to clean that place up
i love that so many people make an
effort to clean up the space behind them
you've done nothing you've done nothing
i've got nothing i just you were like
well time to go talk to conan i guess
i'll just go in the [ __ ] room i was so
bored
the other night that i went on ebay and
i bought a uh autographed
gypsy playbill or got by patty of the
poem oh there you go
well how much can i ask uh you know what
i don't i don't have that information in
front of me but
i i may not have even looked i may have
just clicked
it was one of those nights you know like
sometimes you're just like don't know
what i'm going to do right now i don't
know i'm going to get to sleep
i wonder what signs play bills are on
ebay
well i'll make sure i get the word out
here uh the king of staten island now
available
on blu-ray everyone still has blue rays
right
you still got that blu-ray who doesn't
have a blu-ray right now everyone's got
a blu-ray it's a hot new technology
also you can jam this into a cd player
from the 70s and it will
kind of work yeah that's a guarantee
the extras will work yes uh judd so nice
to talk to you
and i can't i can't wait seriously i i
honestly can't wait till
uh we get to be in this theater together
again
with some funny people and have a real
show with humans that would be such a
blast
we will be back they can't stop it we
shall
return all right judd apatow thank you
and i bow to you
i bow to you